this is amalie
she's an addict
she's also a new mom
her calf adeline is just three weeks old
and she's very important
because the addicts is a critically
endangered species
the addicts is a native of the sahara
desert and once roamed over vast areas
of north africa
they're also known as the screw horn
antelope
it's easy to see why
they are extremely well adapted to life
in the desert
their white coats reflect the scorching
sun and their splayed hoofs are
perfectly tailored for traversing desert
sands
the addicts can also survive extremely
long periods without water
but these adaptations are no help
against humans
the addicts has been hunted nearly into
oblivion
estimates put their population at less
than 200 individuals in just a few
pockets of the sahara
luckily reintroduction efforts and
captive breeding programs like the one
that produce little adeline are helping
the survival of this species that has
all but disappeared from the face of the
earth
this is the addicts
you